welcome to tonight's tactics class we're
going to cover some combinations and
then to mate into puzzles at the end
these combinations are all taken from
the encyclopedia of combinations
published by the chess informant people
from Serbia back in the day chess
informant was the de facto go to book
for grandmasters and Bobby Fischer would
pour through that each it was published
every six months nuts published
quarterly and the even today all the
grandmaster games are annotated by very
good grandmasters that explain things
quite clearly of course it's all done
with notation
anyway they published this very nice
book it has three thousand tactic
examples and they rate them in three
manners there's basic intermediate and
advanced and we'll be doing two basic
two a to intermediate and to advanced
and you'll see that the advanced can be
quite difficult the others are more
solvable but it's fun to see the
advanced ones just to see how the
grandmasters come up with some of these
solutions to that to their chess
positions so the one thing about these
combinations tonight they all follow a
theme and the theme tonight is
interference and what that means in
chess is black is able to defend the
position in the starting position
because his pieces and pawns defend the
key weaknesses earth the key pieces that
are being attacked however white can at
some point make a move that
cuts the defensive diagonal row or file
the communication between black pieces
allowing white to pull off a winning
combination now I think when you study
just tactics it's best to always study a
theme because let's say you have an hour
to study tactics and you can get in five
tactic puzzles in an hour
by studying the same kind of tactic five
different positions you get the pattern
reinforced in your memory now I know
that you can do tactic puzzles on chess
comm which are quite good
the default though is kind of like a
shotgun approach where it randomly
selects the theme it might be night
forks a double attacker or some other
theme and I recommend that you study the
same idea in all four your whole session
because one the patterns reinforce each
other it helps you learn it better
I understand chess come you do have the
option to set it up if you explore the
menus so it's quite doable there too so
that gives us our first clue
the second thing if you look under the
little chessboard on the right you'll
see it says 1-0 well it's white to play
and win that's what that means and if
you look at the names at the top on the
right side the notation board you'll see
it Benko versus rogue bay USA
championship way back in 1963 of course
pal Benko came from from Hungary and was
one of the a1 in the United States Open
United States Championship several times
and he won very many Swiss tournaments
over the years and he would he published
some great articles and books when he
was active and interesting enough the
Polgara fair
we were friends with banco he was of
course much older than the three sisters
but they became good friends their offer
him Hungary so that's an interesting
little thing especially since the Susan
Polgar has set up her program at Webster
College and is a helps develop
grandmasters right here in st. Louis so
anyway we'll jump into this first one so
we know it's white to play and win and
we know there's interference at some
point now it's before you start jumping
to white moves just looking at moves you
know you got a little study the chess
position and see the tactical
opportunities that might exist so I'm
gonna point some out first we'll start
with the White Queen she can move here
checking the black King and attacking
the black work on d1
of course the black Queen defends the
rook so that's adequate the King would
move and that doesn't win but that is a
tactic there's a queen double attack on
the black King and the work on do you
want
we don't have a lot of other tactics the
white knight can't go here here here
without being taken and the work is
blocked by the pawn and it doesn't have
any real attacking moves laterally or
backwards so it looks like our main idea
is this Queen Chuck but the problem is
the black Queen defends the rook well
remember interference that that file the
D file from d7 where the Queen is to d1
that's the line that we need to cut and
the way we can cut it we can move our
knight over here that will block that
will block the Queen from defending the
rook and threaten Queen the Queen check
on the second move so let's say there
was we moved the knight their pawn takes
Knight we do the Queen check the King
moves and then we take the rook so
that's the idea and I think that's gonna
work so we'll just make that Knight move
we cut the line of defense of the Queen
to the rook and by the were also
obviously threatening nine takes Knight
winning and he can't do Knight takes
Knight that would drop his queen
so this that's basically it
pawn takes Czech king over so that's a
pretty little combination but that that
that's the solution to it and so going
back to our starting position you can
see that the first move
that's this interference thing the white
knight interferes with the defense of
the black Queen defending the black rook
allowing the Queen check to win the rook
so we'll go on to the next puzzle
oops you said f11 you thought okay so
here's our next puzzle and this one is
white to win awesome now if you look at
the top on the right side yeah at the
bottom of the little chessboard it says
1-0 white to play and win same theme
there's going to be some defensive line
that's cut and let's look at the players
the name is Stolberg versus Zach it was
in a USSR tournament and it was back way
back in 1938 well turns out that
Stolberg was a famous Swedish
Grandmaster he was the this Swedish
champion and you know back in those days
there were many grandmasters in the USSR
mainly Russia and other countries and
Zach was one of the Russian Grandmaster
so he he's not one of the premier
grandmasters but he was quite good I
mean you had to be really good to play
in the USSR tournaments okay so anyway
white pulls off the wind so let's look
at what White's possible attacking moves
are the one that jumps out first is the
Queen and the knight are attacking the
f7 pawn and if the Queen can take the
pawn the King would have to move to the
corner and would have Queen takes Knight
checkmate of course you can see that the
black Queen defends the pawn so there's
the line that we have to cut now we can
cut it by moving our rook or Bishop up
next to the Queen so the question is do
we cut it with the bishop or the rook
well we have to look into the future to
see it so let's just say we do the rook
obviously he has to do Bishop takes rook
Knight takes rook doesn't cut it Queen
takes pawn check King to the corner
Queen the e8 check the knight has to go
to f8 and Queen takes Knight is
checkmate
and of course Queen takes Rick doesn't
cut it because we do Bishop takes Queen
winning the Queen and we still get Queen
takes pawn check so the only move for
black is to do Bishop takes pawn
allowing us to do Queen takes pawn check
and then the King moves to the corner
but because the bishop move from c8 to
d7 now the black work on a eight
protects the knight and we don't exactly
have a immediate checkmate but what we
do have
you see our white queen is on f7 the
black Bishop is on d7 the black Bishop
can't move because the black Queen is
undefended and we would win the Queen
with Queen takes Queen so somehow we
need to find an attacking move to
threaten checkmate
and the reason we did the work we kept
the bishop back because now the bishop
can retreat to c4 hold on wrong colour
here
the bishop can retreat to c4 whoops
there you go
and reinforce the Queen remember the
white Queens on f7 so now the threat is
Queen the GA checkmate
that means the knight would have to move
somewhere
and we might have the nice oh yeah the
Night Moves and watch this we have this
smothered mate Queen the g8 check rook
takes Queen Knight to f7 checkmate let's
step through it
so our starting move is Rick down
that's our interference move blocking
the Queen from defending f7 the bishop
has to take Queen takes pawn check King
over Bishop back that's why we had to do
the work and not the bishop down we
threaten Queen to GA checkmate if the
knight goes here Knight takes Knight
threatens the Queen and Queen takes g7
checkmate
that's curtains and if he goes over here
we get the very nice smothered mate so
that's a very nice combination so that
Swedish Grandmaster Stolberg was quite
the attacking player he was the Swedish
champion and he was in the top twenty or
thirty okay we'll go on to the next one
this is white to play and win also and
this is another USSR tournament between
two grandmasters someone named Koh dose
and McInnis now I never heard a KO dose
before but McInnis was quite a famous
Grandmaster back in his day this was
played in 1960 for white to play and win
again so let us look at the tactical
possibilities here
the knight could take the paw and check
whoops wrong color take the pawn check
but the king the King would just move
over and I don't see a follow up now the
other thing we have a nice little
possible check with the Queen of course
in that case the bishop would block and
then the Queen the black Queen would
guard the second ring so the black Queen
guards this way okay so we need to
disrupt the black Queen and guarding the
bishop on f7 and potentially the h7 pawn
so the point we need to block is right
where this red square is and it's very
convenient that we have one piece that's
a work on a one they can move to that
square so that's our interference move
and that's the solution the solution so
we make that move and obviously we're
threatening Queen takes Bishop checkmate
Knight takes rook doesn't protect the
bishop and Queen takes would lose the
Queen the pawn takes Queen so the only
move is rook takes Queen and now it
looks like Black has defended himself a
little bit because if we do if we were
to do Queen to h8 he could drop his
bishop back to g8 and if we did pawn
takes rook jack he could do Queen takes
pawn and the Queen defends and then the
King could run over to the Queen side by
going King to be eight
so I was looking at this earlier today
to refresh my memory on this puzzle I've
seen it before and I was wracking my
brain I couldn't really remember it but
it turns out there's a very nice move
here yep
Knight takes f7 and now the threat is
say Knight here picking up the Queen so
black and we still have pawn takes rook
check so there's really nothing better
than where it takes Knight but now
there's no block on the back row so
that's a checkmate move and that's a
very nice combination so but these are
hard to see this is three moves in
advance but to me the hard move to see
King d8 King were Noah we have checkmate
there good good boy yeah so anyway
that's a nice combination but again to
me the tricky moved to C was here
because we saw Queen to h8 check and the
bishop drops back and it's not in to me
it wasn't immediately obvious that
Knight takes bishop I forgot now there's
nothing to go to g8 to block the Queen
check and with that pawn on d6 covers
the king escape to e7 yeah so the king
is trapped okay so we'll go on to the
next puzzle
this time this is a couple Chinese
players I I never heard of either one of
them nan land versus Zil back in 1988
and this time it's black to play and win
then one glance at the position you can
see black does have some nice attacking
chances right off the bat there's a
potential the Queen and Bishop operate
on these diagonals do you wanna flip the
board does that matter control that
control yeah well let's look at it from
blacks point of view might ease it so
you see with that the knight is blocking
the black Bishop and with the knight out
of the way we'd threaten some inroads
with the Queen supported by the bishop
of course we have the black as the
slight problem that white has a counter
defensive move he just takes the bishop
but that means we need to move our
knight to open the bishop line but we
got to cut the book the white rook so
the obvious possible Knight move is here
and that's the square that blocks the
rook from taking the bishop like giving
us time to drop our Queen f3 threatening
Queen to g7 g to checkmate and then
hopefully we also have the black pawn on
f5 and E 5 they can advance to f4 and
once that pawns on f4 pawn takes g3
would open up the rook on f8 so we have
a couple other attacking possibilities
and we have this
low confusing with all those arrows but
then those are essentially are attacking
possibilities and that's what you should
do before you try to solve these look at
the squares you can move your pieces to
really checkmate or hurt the white
position in this case or the opposition
so let's jump into this and we'll do our
knight move
now we're threatening Queen to f3 and he
has nothing really but rook takes Knight
doesn't add anything we just do pawn
takes so he's gonna have to do pull this
is the main line pawn takes and
naturally we drop in here threatening
I'm saying naturally but maybe that's
not it
maybe that's it so we're threatening
Queen to g2 mate the only way to defend
it is to move the knight somewhere and
the logical move is to put it where it
can't be attacked right there now if we
do Queen to h1 check he can run up to f2
we can go to G to check but then he can
run to e1 and protect this Queen and we
kind of run out of threats and here's
this is the hard part to see getting
this far is not it it's it's tricky but
we can get this far but the really hard
move to find is the winning move it's
it's advancing the pawn now with that
pawn up there we threaten Queen down
King up we have pawn takes pawn check
opening the rook then we got our Bishop
Queen and we're converging and we're
gonna win the black queen er or maybe
even get a check made out of it so is
there
defense here and what would it be he's
got we have two possible to have the h1
check
that's a checkmate by the way Queen to
h1 is a checkmate so he's got to bring
his Queen here to cover that checkmate
but if he does that we have pawn takes
pawn and we're on the Queen and if the
Queen moves away from the second row we
have Queen f2 checkmate
and if he moves across the second row we
have Queen the h1 checkmate now he does
have a spite check Queen here check on
the King but we just move our King up
one Square and there's no follow-up
checks for black so that that's pretty
much it you can't really stop Queen to
h1 checkmate
so we'll move on to the next one okay
now we have from 1990 this was played in
a city called Novi Sad do you know where
that is no idea I think it's in Serbia
but I'm not sure the white player is
wall kiewit so that excuse my
mispronunciation of polish names i think
he's a polish player skin Boris though
that's a Slavic name and I think it's in
Novi Sad is Serbia in the former
Yugoslavia this is played in 1990 and
this time it's white to play and win
yeah let's flip the board what was the
role control F
okay white to play and win now once
again we have the Queen and Knight
converging on f7 we also have this
bishop here it attacks there of course
that's defended by Knight and Bishop and
the rook so the Queen defends over there
that's the line we need to break the
Queen's defense and we can drop our
knight in nope we can't drop our knight
in because we need the knight on f7 so
the only piece to drop in there to break
that is the rook and then obviously he's
going to do Bishop takes and we're gonna
do Queen takes pawn Chuck then the black
King can go to one of two squares so you
can go to h8 or h7 and it's not clear
how we're gonna break through here so
we're gonna step into it as far and then
look for the solution let's just step
through the moves it looks tricky work
down Bishop take well we're gonna get
into it and then try to solve it okay so
this simplifies it a little bit we won't
have to think so much in our head now he
can go to h8 or h7h well hh8 we do have
Knight to g6 and we have Knight takes
Bishop check that's true
well the key has to go we have to pick
one square the other now
I think because I looked at this earlier
today so I think pretty clearly the
better move is here but we can double
back to the other move now this is the
next move is the move that's really hard
to find
it's move three for us so it's only
three moves in advance but I challenge
the audience to find the winning move
here because it's not a check and it
doesn't involve an immediate mate or
anything so what's the winning move I
guess the only way I can say it is we
don't have enough horsepower to finish
black off now we have a bishop on g2
what's that doing for us the answer is
nothing now black has no counter threats
he can't do pawn takes Bishop then we
have Knight to g6 checkmate he can't do
Queen takes Knight when Bishop takes
Queen he can't do Queen takes e4 pawn
the night covers now he could do Queen
to d6 plus we can play Knight takes
bishop at some point then we would
threaten Queen takes the undefended rook
but to build our attack we need to bring
our Bishop to g2 somewhere and obviously
the only thing worth attacking is the
knight on f5 so this is the keep the
winning move now one of the good things
about that move is if that Knight moves
out of the way the bishop covers the
Kings escape Square to h7 and we would
have Knight to g6 King up we get a
discovered check which wipes them out
Knight takes bishop discovered check
then we can take the bishop on d7 so I
guess we might be threatening Bishop
well what we're really threatening I
think is Knight takes Bishop
then we're threatening the queen takes
rook and it's stronger having our Bishop
there because it keeps the king in the
corner and we can follow up with Bishop
takes Knight and it gives our King an
escape square if any back row check
should threaten King the g2 so let's see
what what if anything I guess your Queen
d6 like you said yeah let's look at
going to d6 let's see let's take a look
at Bishop to d6 for our second attacking
the knight
- oh okay Bishop to d6 attacking the
knight
we have Knight to g6 check King up well
yeah Bishop takes Knight pawn takes then
we have Queen takes g7 checkmate see if
the bishop comes up
the only thing defending g7 is the
knight which we're going to take out
with Bishop takes Knight okay yeah and
the bishop blocks the Queen from
defending so the bishop can't move so if
he tries to say Queen up then the
similar stuff should happen now he does
have the check on d1 but our King is
safe going up to g2 and there's no
follow-up checks so I'm thinking now we
just do Knight takes bishop and we
threaten Queen takes rook
if the rook moves of course if it goes
here we could just take it and if he
does this spike check we just come up
here you know some people were
suggesting earlier to play g4 instead of
Bishop takes that by that's the
interesting they've also I think well
what move g4 they try to kick the
defending night out but we're right here
not quite sure where they were in the
stream but like all right here any
moment
no maybe probably after Bishop before
then like like Queen up yeah yeah g4
would be interesting yeah yeah g4 might
work but it's unnecessary because Knight
takes Bishop crashes through it we're on
the rook
plus we've got the Bishop takes Knight
Knight takes but we got all kinds of
possibilities well you can't do rook
here so they can't really even threaten
our Knight he could go here but now I
think he's pretty defenseless you know
and that Queen B one line that you had a
second ago King G - there's no nonsense
own I teach for doesn't work because you
have a bishop to take it makes it much
like to these Queen here yeah
King here and then I was there's a check
yeah there's night h4 and 93 well h4 is
guarded by the bishop I missed it
oh yeah I get so much stability
otherwise well I would mean I could move
the King here to H square Oh laughter oh
and if he checks here I take it there's
no four checks
yeah well I'm not sure I think it looks
like you I think it goes night here
check and if if there's a queen check
then you then what can we hide oh then
we can do this and if here oh yeah the
Queen's guarding it so he runs out of
check and if he checks here we go up
there
that's it they can't even play g5 which
helps well wait a minute I pinned wait a
minute
oh no if he goes here if we go H he
could go there what's wrong oh it's but
then we I was thinking we could go to
the white square of g4 and he doesn't
have anything but it spins so it's moot
yeah all right let's go to the next one
how are we doing on time we have 20
minutes we're making good headway here
we're also getting to the really hard
ones
remember basic to basic to intermediate
to really hard ones oh that was the last
hard one oh now we're in our mate in two
puzzles and I would have to say these
are hardest oh she was yeah boy yeah now
this Danny is here with me Danny Machuca
and he and I about a year and a half ago
or so we started trying to solve these
things and we would spend an hour and a
half racking our brains on it yeah
and sometimes we solved it sometimes we
didn't but since then I have to I've
learned from doing a lot of them that
there's a method rather than looking at
all whites possible moves there's so
many possible moves what you have to do
is analyze the black king position and
the white king position and you want to
look for first let's do the white King
it's quite simple you just make sure
there are no checks on the white king
and you can see that there's no possible
pieces in this that can check the white
king the plot the black pawn on a5
shields the white king
there's no [ __ ] that the white square
bishop is way over here on the black
white square Bishop is on h5 blocked by
pawn and Knight it can't even move so
and the knight can
nothing can reach the white king so yeah
sometimes there is a check on the white
king you have to be able to take the
piece of the checks and do a checkmate
so that's what you look for but the real
focus is on the black King you look for
the escape squares so there is an escape
square here right here
wrong color though let's try this the
black King can move up one Square and
then he could have another square in
front of that so we have to work out a
checkmate to cover that King move now
the other thing to do is look at the
pieces the white pieces and pawns that
surround the black King and you'll see
that some of the squares are covered by
two pieces they rook and Knight let's
look at the that white knight on h4 it
covers and the RIC covers f5 and that's
a possible checkmate at some point
rook to f5 check it doesn't work right
away cuz he could take art the night cuz
the work defends the knight
plus he could still move up but the fact
that the rook and the knight cover that
square means we could move the work or
the knight and the other piece still
covers the square so we do that with the
other squares the white rook on d1
covers that whole file now that white
rook is the end of the white bishop on
a3
they both cover the same square on d6
well that's Bishop to d6 as a possible
checkmate if the black bishop moves off
the diagonal we got a couple guesses I
don't know if we're ready for accepting
guesses yet but 98 and
g6 our people are looking for those are
good guesses but let me continue the
thought process cuz we can whittle it
down a little bit I can tell you for a
fact that that Bishop on a3 is not
moving it might do a checkmate by going
to d6 but there's nothing to be gained
moving it anywhere the king is not going
to move that rook on d1 is not going to
move and the two pawns on c3 and c4 they
they cover important squares but they're
not gonna move that rook on f6 is not
gonna move the pawn protects the work
it's blocked the pawn can't move and
this Bishop this Bishop here is not
gonna move but if that Knight moves that
Bishop is going to cover that diagonal
and take away the escape square that's
part of our checkmate now the other
thing is someone said now we're ready to
look at the suggestions so we have 96-98
to cookie ones to people for rookie one
and a rookie for now let's cover rook to
e1 rook to e1 is a potential checkmate
except the black queen can block Queen
the e3 if the black queen diagonal gets
blocked by say a knight or some other
move then worth the e1 is the checkmate
it's part of the solution but it's not
the key move now what were the other if
someone said Knight to DA a now Knight
to d8 is a very attractive move because
it threatens rook to e6 the knight
vacates the square and rook to e6 covers
the escape square and is checkmate
so that threatens checkmate in one and
[Applause]
black Candice
stop that checkmate in different ways
but it will allow some other checkmate
so whoever said Knight to d8 that is the
key move now the reason they call it the
key move it's like a lock or evolved in
a bank you find the move no matter what
black does he can stop rook to e6
checkmate
it opens up a different checkmate now
okay so first of all he could do Knight
takes Knight and that stops but it opens
up the Queen line see that the the Queen
then comes back here there's your
checkmate
and this is how it works every way he
stops that so if the knight goes here we
have the same thing Queen in checkmate
so that pretty much does that night oh
and we said the King could escape here
is there a checkmate here there is a
checkmate here the King here the knight
is pinned by the Queen so and the other
Knights pinned by the bishop so there's
no way to block nice yeah okay these are
very good lover that's clever yeah okay
alright so the King can't move up we got
to the escape Square covered we're still
threatening there and he has other ways
to stop it let's think of another way to
stop it first of all he could move his
Queen here and that covers the e6 square
but the Queen moving opens up some other
possibility that we have to discover I
was gonna say which is
it was here a minute ago
what is it
Oh who was it who said rook to e1
remember the Queen was blocking on the
e3 81 so there's your rook to e1
checkmate
okay yeah the Queen had to guard III
that's an over we're at Queen's right
okay now there's another Queen move of
course that really is is a no-brainer
because the knight takes and wait a
minute that's an excuse can we do
brookie one again is that the theme
whenever the Queen moves rook e1 yeah
work the e1 again yeah yeah we're - you
won same theme yeah yeah that's it see
that see how the little mate shows up
when you get it right
all right now let's see if there's
anything else if the knight moves the
other night or the bishop moves which we
have the rook check
I see
okay let's try Knight over here that
that allows the the black work on a6 to
cover the threatened Knight to e6 chip
the work to e6 checkmating but it blocks
the Queen from the f7 square and our
black White Queen now covers the e4
xscape square ah previously blocked by
the knight
Wow 98 was very strong yeah so that's
that look we have some questions about
alternative like answers okay we'll have
to figure out why they're wrong you mean
in the starting Deanna starting position
all right so one person was asking what
if we just do Queen takes Queen and then
whatever they do
rook you one mate let's clear the board
of all the errors so the the question
was Queen takes Queen yeah with the idea
of rookie won since rook e1 was stopped
by it okay the Queen block well that's
true but I got to tell you that these
puzzles typically don't start with the
capture or a check because the the
composers think it's too blunt yeah they
want to be subtle that assumes oh okay
now specifically though find out why it
doesn't work
rook e1 idea I guess they can wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
Queen takes okay it is Queen takes okay
Queens yeah with the idea oh no I broke
over where everything we block over
there just get rid of the Queen okay now
now now now we gave up the Queen to d5
checkmate remember we're threatening
here or threatening czar there maybe the
bishop can just come to ya the bishop
can come up and go I gum up the work
yeah you're just a single turn I think
yeah and that there's no immediate
checkmate that I can see because we
still have the escape square e for ya so
work to d5 check doesn't cut it
Queen to c7 check doesn't cut it because
the bishop blocks Bishop back it's
checkmate pathetic doesn't count
yeah what's another truck someone else
had another try
besides going takes Queen I think the
other okay we go on to the next one okay
all right
now this one's easier you see there's
much fewer pieces no Queens this is
gonna be much easier not harder but we
have to do it in a similar fashion there
are no checks on the White King so we
can now let's focus on the black King
the rook the white rook this one go and
this Rick comes this way and of course
is the possible check here and if that
night were to move there's a possible
rook check right there too so those are
possible rook checks now the king isn't
gonna move it's just going to sit there
now if the if the white rook were to
move it would free up the bishop could
go here check and the bishop protects
the rook which is important so the work
the that rook is defended by night and
Bishop meaning we could move the knight
or the bishop if we want to plus we
could move the rook somewhere and we
would still have the squares covered now
the night now let's look at the white
bishop on c6
we could move it but the black Kings on
a black square that means we're not
gonna move the white bishop there's
nothing to be gained
now the but the white bishop on the
black square it can't check the King
unless we move the white rook and we
would have a rook move and Bishop to c5
checkmate that's a possibility but I
don't give it a high probability because
the rook covers all those squares on the
C file and if you were to move it along
the fifth row you'd open up squares they
could move to King to c4 so that rooks
not gonna move that it's not gonna be
the bishop on a3 the rook the King the
work on a1 or the bishop it's gonna be
the knight move so what is the square
for the knight move now look when the
knight moves out of the way we have Rick
here checkmate protected by the bishop
so that means that that Knight can go
anywhere now the black King is on a
black square and the Knights going to
move to a black square then it'll
threaten a check on two white squares b5
and f5 if it goes to c3 and pawn takes
Knight doesn't count it because of rook
to e4 checkmate
and we're threatening to to Knight
Switzer checkmates now that's the
solution
no matter now he can stop the rook to f5
checkmate that were also threatening
worth to d5 that's checkmate too isn't
it
so let's just do the easy one pawn takes
Knight doesn't cut it because rook here
and you can see the checkmate over here
yeah okay now the work could move and
stop that checkmate but it doesn't stop
that one does it
okay now the knight could move and that
stops the rook checkmate and it stops
that checkmate doesn't it but it doesn't
stop the knight checkmate though it
works covered by the bishop see we had
the two night checks all right now we
could do Knight takes but it's the same
thing in fact oh it's not the same thing
with that rook on he has an escape
square on e3 but the other check covers
it and there's our checkmate there it is
that covers the ice that covers it okay
thanks for coming okay yeah we have one
question only before I go is that why
didn't king c1 work first-mover yeah I
think it's pretty well first of all what
does King to see what's your checkmate
Oh Bishop to G the problem is let's see
if there's a problem
oh look a check how about pawn up check
Bishop check we block that stops it and
three you might get it in three moves
that doesn't count
yeah there's a good answer but good try
checkmate
alright any others that was it yeah okay
thanks for coming have a good night